2021 and beyond is gonna have a lot to
offer for the xbox series x
and s so let's check out nine big games
that are coming to the consoles
halo infinite doesn't really need an
introduction the sixth main installment
of the iconic first-person shooter
franchise is heading to the xbox series
x and
s in 2021 originally set to be a console
launch title developer 343 industries
delayed halo infinite to 2021 to ensure
the quality of the game
meets its standards halo infinite will
be putting a renewed focus on master
chief after drifting away from him
slightly in halo 5. the series is known
for its top tier multiplayer and we're
excited to see what new changes will
come to infinite's multiplayer
based on video showcases the single
player has had some tweaks to gameplay
including adding a grappling hook and
reintroducing sprinting and sliding and
of course we can't forget about our boy
craig
let's see if he makes it to the final
cut next year
it's been a long time coming but
psychonauts 2 will hit the next gen in
2021
and even better it'll be available on
xbox game pass on day one
after developer double fine was acquired
by xbox the team was able to expand the
game bring back cut content and create
the game in its true trippy vision
jack black will also be a part of
psychonauts 2. he's voicing a character
and a recent trailer showed raz's
consciousness exploring a bizarre world
within a jar with jack black lending his
beautiful singing voice to the
soundtrack
resident evil village is the eighth main
installment of the resident evil series
but the team working on the game says
this will be a unique experience in the
survival horror genre
set in a beautiful but terrifying world
the story will take place several years
after the events of resident evil 7 with
returning favorite chris redfield
being a big reason why ethan's life gets
turned upside down
once again we've seen a few 4k trailers
that show off various creatures and
detailed environments and it
looks pretty unsettling according to the
game's producers there will be zero
loading times and new mechanics that
they say
will make this the most immersive
resident evil to date
i'm scared already for the first time on
consoles and after being dormant for
over
10 years the stalker series is back with
stalker 2. debuted during the xbox
series x event stalker 2
cinematic trailer showed off some new
spooky environments in the game's take
on areas surrounding the chernobyl
exclusion zone an xbox blog post
mentioned you'll be able to play as a
bounty hunter in the contaminated zone
that is on the hunt for treasure and
secrets the game will have a simulated
living world and developer gsc game
world claims events will be happening
constantly whether or not you're there
to witness them there will also be
different endings based on your choices
and an open world format that will be
one of the biggest to date
stalker 2 will also be available on xbox
game pass on day 1.
in lord of the rings golem you play as
smeagle or gollum and explore a new
story that starts in parallel with
frodo's but on a different
side of middle earth entirely the
decisions you make will change the feel
of the game as you will always be
playing as either smeagle or golem as
the dominant persona
and that can influence animations
soundscapes certain gameplay situations
and in-game dialogue the game will
mostly be non-combat but gollum's
persona does have the ability to
stealthily take down enemies
even if it comes with big risks the
game's lead game designer martin wilks
also said they want players to carefully
weigh these encounters after all
golem strings lie in cunning not combat
warhammer 40000 dark tide is a visceral
four-person co-op action game where you
fight off hordes of enemies as various
classes that have a range of styles
from classic tight range melee combat to
range combat that is said to be more
complex this time around a short trailer
was revealed at the xbox series x event
but there was also gameplay screenshots
on dark tides steam page that gave us a
close look at the enemies and atmosphere
for the game
while the co-op action is what
developers fat shark have been known for
they mentioned in a blog post our hope
is that we can really deliver on some
truly hybrid combat that's both
accessible
yet boasts a high skill ceiling offering
the same opportunity for mastery
regardless of whether you have a last
gun or a chain sword in your hands
now the next few games don't have
confirmed release dates but could
surprise us with 2021 launches so we
still felt they were worth mentioning
just in case unknown nine awakening is a
third person action-adventure game where
you play as a young girl named haruna
who is haunted by visions of her own
death and is trying to understand the
mysterious powers within herself that
allow her to manipulate the unseen the
developers also mentioned that haruna
will meet a mentor who will help her
hone her abilities and access
a hidden dimension known as the fold
this narrative driven game was revealed
at gamescom 2020's opening night live
with a captivating cinematic trailer and
has been on my mind ever since awakening
is the first game from reflector
entertainment and will be a part of
story world the extended multimedia
unknown 9
universe everwild is a brand new ip
for rare and it's an adventure game set
in a magical and
untamed world where you play as an
eternal who can sense and feel how magic
flows through nature which will
eventually be an important role in how
you play
it's up to you to save this beautiful
land from ominous threats and protect
life with the power of nature
on your side the lush and vibrant
trailers we've seen so far further
showcase how you can bond with nature
and the creatures within it to do
certain tasks like tearing down
trees but no official gameplay has been
released
ninja theory announced back in 2019 that
senua's saga held blade 2
was coming to the series x and pc and
one of the first games confirmed for
xbox smart delivery the first game
tackled things like mental health issues
and battling your personal demons but we
don't know much about hellblade 2's
gameplay
or its story just yet for now all we do
know is that it's set in 9th century
iceland and looks to be even darker than
its predecessor
since ninja theory was acquired by
microsoft fans have high hopes and
expectations for the size and scale
of the game there are even more games on
the horizon but these were our favorites
which of these games are you adding to
your wishlist got any in mind that
weren't on our list
let us know down below and stay tuned to
gamespot for more details on all things
xbox series x and s thanks for watching
you